e
good morning everyone the time being
10:05 we'll get going on our work
session for
today and I will open the work session
on HB
1203 representative
PL to me this is a no-brain a rot to
pass uh because we had testimony that uh
the from the gaming industry that they
don't mind that they did need the to
rent at one time but they don't anymore
because the wages have gone up and so
this is would benefit Charities and they
well okay anybody else on hb23
representative
Aly so the idea would be that we send
another bill to the Senate trying to get
them to move on this I'm not sure
there's any opposition to the Senate the
idea is to remove the rents charge to
Charities and and that we got in
testimony from the don't mind the Comm
the the gaming industry that they don't
mind this so I don't know what the
objection would be for I don't either
but we don't know why representative Sen
Senator Lang is sitting on the bill that
contains that so you're talking about
sb112 which we passed out of um the
house with an amendment and um and we'll
see several bills today that are pieces
of that uh Bill yes representative
shamberg uh yes representative PL on um
line
I'll get it right here in a minute lines
18 and 19 says any service agreement
entered into by the chable organization
shall be submitted with the chable
organization's license application for
review by The Lottery Commission does
that mean all new or is that all present
ones will also be resubmitted I
I I'm not expert but I believe all of
them would have to be submitted because
it's a new every time you get a week or
anybody else any other thoughts comments
representative
Ames it's really the same question that
representative Aly raised um this other
bill or bills I don't know even whether
there's another one floating around um
it' be really helpful to know what the
status of um
the other bill that contains the same
provision on rent is and that's just a
question if there's uh I'd like to have
an answer if I could get
one as far as we know at this point the
the they're sitting on that Bill yes
representative duet yes as I know it or
at least the information I have is the
senator Lang has another piece of
legislation that mimics what we passed
amended uh
sb112 um with a couple changes
um one can only smise as to why that
bill is being held over on that side and
like I said we're going to see other
components I myself filed other pieces
of legislation which we'll hear one of
them I think today um that were included
in that Amendment so um it's I guess
that Shaman's prerogative whether to
bring that up or not but I hear where
you're coming from we've already solved
this problem why are we handling it in
components at this point
right Mr chairman yes does shamber just
for the tech representative PL is a very
knowledgeable person but on lines 18 and
19 but does the Lottery
Commission could they give an
explanation will that be the case of
resubmitting all applications will come
back to the them if this is passed for
them to look
at well I see we have director McIntyre
uh good morning my name is Valerie King
I oversee the division that um does the
CH of gaming side of Lottery uh as far
as 18 and 19 about um us viewing the um
agreements we do that already so it
would just be a
continuation um but while I'm up here I
just wanted to point out that and this
is noted in the fiscal note that when
they
um re worded the section they eliminated
the 35% goes to
Charities so that language should be put
back
in it it doesn't say it anywhere else in
here okay thank you yes representative
Alman thank you uh well you're there uh
there is no fiscal note on this one but
um can you tell us since they um
repealed and
reenacted I hate these uh could you tell
us what has changed in
this yeah and I can give you my copy it
was a note on the uh LSR that I can give
you and basically when it repealed RSA
uh 287 DD colon9 Roman numeral
2A that is where it specified I think it
also mentioned rent but as part of that
same sentence it said that the Chari
shall receive 35% of all the proceeds
and so when they took out the rent they
accidentally took everything out could
you repeat that on the the ref I can
give this to you if you'd like oh great
if we could get copies I I can give you
this
287d Dash I mean colon
19 Roman numeral 2 and then a in
parentheses that's where it originally
was located and when they um revised the
it hold on one second representative
Ames yeah I I I had meant to bring that
up and I'm glad you did and I think uh
my my belief is that we need to hold
this bill and get an amendment to
correct this this mistake that was
unintentional it just happened and um
I'm I'm all for this bill um once we get
it
perfected okay represent PL Mr chair
I'll take it upon myself to get the
amendment thank
you representative Aly yeah I just
wanted to make sure that's the only
thing that
changed well that's the important part
that changed that that's
missing repr sorry are there any other
little words here and there that might
make a difference there was nothing that
we identified other than the 35% was um
eliminated representative PL would you
like a co-sponsor on
that sure thank you
sir I'll let you do the work oh I wanted
was just about to suggest
that that you both look at the ex the
existing language
um so representative PL um can you see
if by chance we might get that Amendment
for tomorrow's exec session soon as I
have a break from here okay as soon as I
have a break from here thank
you anything else anybody else on this
1203 okay seeing nothing else we'll
great
okay I'll now open the work session on
HP
1255 relative to Historic
moratorium representative plat it's a
simple enough Bill uh this is
representative Horgan's bill I believe
it's just extending the moratorium for a
couple more years but is that a good
idea or a bad idea I took to
representative DEET is that a good idea
or a bad idea I don't know I think the
so but as far as I'm concerned i' I'd
vote an itl on this yeah we have this
Mor um we have the moratorium in in the
amendment on S sp12 but we also
have I believe there's another bill
coming up not sure which number right
now but we're that's addressed as well
um yes represent fellows can somebody
please update me like if we do nothing
what is is there a moratorium and what
is the
date I believe if we do nothing the
year we do nothing it's
microphone microphone please sorry I
thought I did it um if we do nothing
or if nothing is done to change the
existing law then the existing
law um that currently contains
restrictions on who can run this kind of
Casino um will continue without those
restrictions that's my understanding is
that right it's it's specific to HHR not
the yeah specific HHR and to uh to the
ability to open or not a new
casino but it's
say we're trying to do we're trying to
do something as I understand it to
limitation yes we have this in another
um I think it is it
hb15
25 okay any other thoughts comments
1255 all right seeing none close the um
1389 this bill would allow the winner of
anonymous representative PL I heard from
the Lottery Commission they can already
R do that but but this would make it
clear in the statute that they could
unless they give affirmative Ascent that
Anonymous I think we will be good to
McIntyre uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh I'm Charlie
McIntyre Lottery director um one of the
things I should point out at first is
the way this is drafted it actually is
impacting the tri-state Lotto
compact so it act I don't know if you
can change it because it's an agreement
between three states s the exact
language and this exact language was
negotiated by the three states in
1985 and the only person still remaining
from that period of time is the first
governor sonunu who signed the bill um
and so when you make changes to the
Commission in this bill you're changing
the Tri-State commission as to what they
can and cannot do and so you couldn't
change if a winner in New Hampshire won
in Vermont you can't change Vermont law
obviously it's U jurisdictional and you
know and so the Lottery Commission for
New Hampshire is RSA
284 which gave the Lottery Commission
541a Authority Under rulemaking and our
prize claiming is based on rulemaking
through jail
car representative
Aly thank you um we had a discussion of
this and and there were other things
that on Charlie mentioned that earlier
that uh are difficult uh in just doing
this in blanket form they seem to hold
uh lotteries in public with with people
and everybody sees who won it um which
you'd have to stop doing I didn't know
about those yeah um but um what we
wanted to do was hold it and form a
study
committee which is something we haven't
um been using but just get a few people
together with Charlie and Valerie
and if Valerie I guess Valerie isn't
involved in this but um to work out a
bill it does does this but doesn't
destroy things that are already going on
that have nothing to do with an
amenity and also I was thinking if we
ought to look at the
rules if the rules don't say on when
somebody comes to collect their money
you can tell them you can be anonymous
or not and I think we have to put that
in law if I could speak to that um M yes
so there's a difference between
confidentiality and
publicity and so we list all the winners
who wi over $600 on our website on a tab
that's not particularly well looked at
very infrequently but we actually ask
the winners if over $600 to sign a media
form if indeed we're going to use their
information or likeness on our social
media and they sign it that they agreed
to do it and they fill out their name
and address and even who's in the
photograph with them and so it's I
looked at this and did some research
with our trade Association we're in the
middle ground of keeping folks Anonymous
there are some states where it is
absolutely forbidden you have to give
your name it's public regardless and
then there are some states that
absolutely keep it secret like Montana
you they can be anonymous forever uh and
we're in the Middle where it's if you
wanted to like we're not going to
publicize your name unless we ask you
too we actually had a firefighter to win
a big prize last two weeks ago would
have been a great story he didn't sign
we don't talk about it
um and then there's some states that
have a dollar value you know 10 over
10,000 you could be anonymous quar
million you could be anonymous half a
million 10 million um but if you go on
it's a lot of work it would be a lot of
work to publicize all of our winners
there are almost you know thousand a
month so um that's just information for
the committee's
consideration represent PL given that I
wasn't opposed to the idea of a study
committee but given what director
McIntyre just said do we need this bill
at all or any
Bill like it right now is is are there
rules that govern that anamin no it's
actually just we do do it out of
courtesy candidly for our player base
nobody nobody wants to service our
players more than I do candidly and so
if somebody doesn't want to be on
publicity for whatever reason we won't
we just won't um other abs of them
signing a document saying sure I'll be
publicity and it's not you I can hand
the form out if you want it's not like
it's fine print it's very much like hey
I agree to do this um
so you know it's obviously your choice
but it's we require some work because
we'd have to change jail car rules as
well um and we'd have to rewrite this
bill into 284 as to where it fits
because there's not really any language
of 284 as to prize claiming that's not
done by rule as part of our relationship
with our
players so one of the one of the reasons
you're using this form instead of
um uh putting it in rules we the rules
could then be in in um not violation but
in in conflict with the Tri-State
Lottery correct correct and there is no
conflict with our other associations but
that one certainly that one's codified
in law I don't know why it was done that
way the tri state is very unique in the
sense of it was the first multi-state
agreement that ever existed for
purposes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
in the coup's case we talked about last
time Charlie Temple was involved yes did
they sign that document no no very much
No in fact so we have a
rule I need to check to see that you're
an eligible person to play so that like
me for example or my wife can't play so
we say we check to make sure you're not
an eligible list also that you don't
have an asset for child support so I was
ordered by judge Temple specifically to
check to make sure that person was not
ineligible but um I only kept their
identity secret so only myself and one
other person knew their identity and so
you representative
fellows so there's a difference between
publicizing somebody's name in and
keeping it
private so right now you don't publicize
anybody's name unless they agree well
there's a list on our website that's
kept under winners list every month
right right and I will I would ask the
question almost in from my seat is has
this been a problem for anybody of the
folks you represent most of the vast
vast majority of the winners that walk
into my office win a th000 2,000 5,000
that's not you know difficulty money
that's you know you're buying around
that night for everybody but you're not
you know being hounded for car loans and
stuff and
so I've personally not heard of an issue
other than the big Winners that would
have an issue and candidly almost to a
person they've come in with legal
representation and candidly I will give
that advice always when they walk in go
find a lawyer just do it right because
you're going to want not just a lawyer
you're going to want an accountant for
tax purposes as well so
um the fact that we allow trusts and we
do has quelled what I would suggest is a
problem for the folks who would have
trouble with you know
people so follow up yeah sorry so I'm
trying to figure out let's forget about
the small amounts yeah we talk we're 10
I could might what if I win 10 million
Tri-State meab buuck and at the same
time I or a different day I
earn I win 10 million in Powerball
because megabuck you told me the rules
are different yes so can somebody under
right to know or something or other even
and I don't and I don't want it
publicized can somebody find out if you
claim in your own name the answer is yes
correct if you claim in your own name
the answer would be yes somebody would
find out how and how did they find out
well they would it would be on our site
under the list of winners and then they
would be subject to 91a uh record
requests abing you going to court and
getting a court order because you filed
it in your own
name just one more question so so you
told us there some states said just
nothing is it wouldn't it how could we
make it be not public if it's over a
certain amount um and and they sign
their
name we'd have to rewrite right RSA 284
and then obviously I'd have to I don't
know the process when a law trumps a
jail car rule uh how that
works I'm on jail car okay yeah jail car
has to conform to to what the statute is
statute comes first of and if the
statute were to change to be
inconsistent with the rules the rules
would have to be
changed I know mean it's never
experienced it it's never happened
before for
us did Lottery have a position on this
bill yeah we're opposed to it we're
actually if you're looking at the
Spectrum we're in the middle ground
folks who win enough money can figure
out a way
to claim anonymously and candidly the
players will often on social media kind
of support the decision to claim an a
trust um for lots of reasons there's
also tax benefits as well um I I imagine
I didn't study tax law um but it's
it makes it hard for us like for example
the way this bill is written 14o font
that they're it's Anonymous unless we
get them to ass sign essentially like a
mortgage payment
um it makes our job harder and like as
representative Aly suggested when I said
before we DT a number of drawings
publicly we give away a bunch of money
and we wouldn't be able to do any of
those either and they're they're very
popular and very noteworthy every time
we do it the track it's almost always on
M that night and and press everywhere so
okay thank you representative ORS would
you believe I find this bill I we should
itl
this representative PL I could agree
with representative ORS but I do like
the idea of interim studying it so that
we could uh put put a committee together
and see if we can't come up with
something acceptable to the Lottery
purpose well it wouldn't be stud uh
representative do just just a real quick
question for the director on
average annually prices above say $5
million annually you know you're talking
one or two yeah it's really it's a low
number I mean we we have been fortunate
in the last six years we've had three
winners over 100 million which is we
were just named well not just about six
months ago the luckiest state in the
country um that's so statistically
anomalous I can't even describe it but
it's representative
roir thank you and U so just looking at
the
law and and and I i' I've heard what you
said I've read the law the current law
not not what's being proposed here
and so tell me if I'm misunderstanding
this the what the law says is I'm going
to read it because I may I'm not an
attorney but um says the financial tax
trust or personal records filed received
maintained or produced by the Commission
in connection with payment of a prize as
provided in this section shall be
confidential period then it goes on to
say something which I think I I think
the uh my colleague across the way asked
this but it does say such record shall
not be deemed public records under
91a so they would be confidential then
correct if I'm understanding 91a so you
you're citing
287 287 F10 yes so that like I said
that's the Tri-State compact so that
only applies to
trate it doesn't apply so when it says
commission there it means the Tri-State
commission not the New Hampshire Lottery
Commission and
if I understand the 1985
logic financing statements referred back
then to how we paid for the prize
payments going
forward so if I may so the commission
Tri State commission 1985 that I'm
assuming that had to do with Tri-State
megabuck that came about that time so
this doesn't even apply to Powerball
Mega Millions 98% of what we sell so
this is I I would agree with interim
study I mean this this is not this is
not what the co-sponsors wanteded I I I
believe even so no and we weren't
consulted on it so I certainly wouldn't
have drafted it 287 yeah I think it's I
don't believe it's ready I I I couldn't
go along with
this okay I just want to make sure
people understand difference between
interim study and a and creating a study
committee um
so I'm not so which what do you stand on
that uh you know if the if the if the
committee feels like
this is a pressing issue U to move
forward which i i i i as as somebody who
thinks values privacy I think a study
commiss committee uh would be
appropriate moving forward with with
this
ENT if it's the purview of this the the
the committee I could go either way I
guess is what I'm saying you know
anything but
OTP if we form a committee does that
have to be enacted in law or could be an
informal committee yeah so just an
informal committee so I interim study
this form an informal committee work
with director McIntyre to come up with
something acceptable for next
term representative Aly so I just I want
just make oh I'm sorry I yeah represent
Aly had her hand up first did you have a
no I I just wanted to point out that we
could have a uh subcommittee on this
which is the term for it and then uh and
then if they can't come to a conclusion
in time for getting the bill in it's
study that's a possibility it it it
could be a tall order to get that uh in
line in time but uh representative
Ames um I guess I'm jumping the
line uh representative fellows
so the words that you read to us about
the um Tri-State
compact can we just use those same words
to apply
to everything over 5 million or two
million or something like that I'd
really want to look at it in terms of
crafting it deliberately I don't I don't
like sort of doing this on the shooting
from the hip on okay lot legal changes
but but right now if you win Tri-State
megabuck then your name automatically is
is you you'd have to ask to make your
correct represent
um I think it's it's clear that this
bill is not an a ought to pass bill and
in it could be an ideal but uh in terms
of studying it and trying to figure out
maybe there is something here um and
it's not the expression goes just a a a
uh solution looking for a problem um uh
and I I think there's something genuine
um lurking behind this about privacy and
confidentiality and at least being
definitively assured that it uh is okay
the way we are now and I have no doubt
about it that you're
balancing all these interests and making
it come out in a good way um and I sort
of lean towards itl for that reason but
if we're going to study it I think you
alluded to the difficulties if uh if we
do a study committee within the existing
frame before the deadline for reporting
this bill out it's really going to be
hard to do anything
meaningful um and uh if we do interim
study this is uh an election here and um
I think there's room for interim studies
on important issues I don't know whether
realistically I mean other people can
judge this I'm perfectly willing to
participate in an interim study on on
this particular issue but it does line
up besides a whole host of other um uh
pressures that each of us have on our
time and uh so I'm not sure what I I'm
recommending I'm thinking out loud I
guess as I say these
things yes thank you for those thoughts
I think um I mean the other way this can
go is if it goes itl um it certainly
does not stop those who are passionate
about this area to work on it and come
year did you have some no I just say
next year I was just saying but yeah
given what you just said I guess I could
go with itl cuz any study might be the
same result uh but come up with a bill
for next
year anybody
else okay thank you um we'll close the
1389 I'll now open the work session on
HB
1525 relative to Historic horse racing
licensing
okay yeah I do we have a draft Amendment
because you said that it had an error in
it that was the other
one sorry there's a drafting error in
this and I have yet to produce that my
bad I can get that done today that'd be
great yeah if we if we could we
tomorrow and I think the drafting error
was on line four the word approved
should be applied
for that was it
okay yeah represent El
me and I think somebody just said that
this is the one that we could put our
on correct I I filed this uh this
component which is you know part of the
amended
sb12 um prior to us voting on that
Amendment and my apologies for not
getting the the uh the amended version
here for you yeah but this one right now
uh has the moratorium in it this is a
full
moratorium after the date inclusive of
the it's basically the same language uh
that we put in amended uh sp12 it's just
that one
component yeah and and you know just to
be clear although we don't have the
amendment here today it's a simple
change on line four approved to approved
by would change to applied
for
appli you mean applied applied for to
the Lottery Commission just English
that's all oh we're missing the word to
okay all right yes I don't want to this
slip away I just want to make sure we
get the right Amendment um so
um so on line four we'd uh we'd uh add
in the pending applications I understand
that um I was just looking down
further
um where at uh we have the language a
game operator employer holding a license
prior to October
18 2023 shall be eligible Etc is that to
need to have the application I I think
yeah so that's line8 also no that's uh
okay figure out get the
appli can't hear so um representative
Ames you're saying the word to was
missing uh on line 10 is that no line 10
is shall be
eligible it's back at the very beginning
of the
line
uh but the license refers to holding a
license let's see a game operator the
sentence that begins on line nine game
operator employer holding a
license prior to October 18 shall be
eligible for license sh to sell and and
um maybe maybe that's our r stand I I
don't know whether we need to have have
your
microphone
sorry all right representative duet do
you see a issue with that
wording from line The End of Line nine
through line 10 I I think it probably
would would cover if we inserted uh
holding Andor applied for something to
that effect okay
my recommendation is that uh
representative duet take it away to the
drafting attorney and make sure that uh
included in the group that can go
forward with uh these this type of games
are the applicants that we're talking
about uh in the first line at line
four that when somehow somehow in the
rest of the language we haven't dropped
them that's
all yeah okay rosent PL okay this is a
permanent moratorium is
that is a permanent moratorium permanent
or was something we could visit two or
three years because I'm not sure well
it's uh represent PL it's the same thing
that applies all the time one
legislature cannot hold the next
legislature uh to something so next year
it could be changed I'd like to speak to
that too if I
represent exactly right about the
legislature having the last word at any
point in time um we're trying to get
this moratorium straightened out before
the
statute um that that uh sets
limits um expires we're trying to get a
get a bill through and adopted by the
legislature that's more or less right um
as best we can determine before that
time July 1 I think of this year
um in the meantime a commission that
representative Jed and I I think
representative
Jan uh sit on um is working on the
larger question a larger set of
questions related to gaming that
um in a general sense include this this
issue it may well be that out of that
event comes out of that work comes a a
Solution that's different from what
we're talking right now this just gets
us into a a a position that's acceptable
going forward in until something else
comes along just and and that again
endorses your point that the legislature
in the end can move in a different
you any other comments question
representative PL so what I'm hearing is
ought to pass as amended when we get the
amended
yeah okay I'm going to end the work
session uh yeah R an on I just ask is
there anything that can be done about
transferring
licenses what in what regard what's your
well question we now have one owner who
owns at least four of these
casinos one of them they haven't
finished building yet that's the one in
Lebanon but
on monopol monopolizing all of these
idea represent represent uh yes
Ames it's really the same point the
commission definitely has that uh
question um before it and uh that'll be
out res set did you
have I I totally agree representative
Ames
um although in in
here U I'm I'm going to hold my
commentary in in here it does speak of
uh not transferring or
so
one all right close the work session on
HB
1525 I'll now open the work session on
HB 1549 relative to buying amount
deductions collected during the
operation of games of chance repres PL
I'm all right with to pass on this one
we heard eloquent testimony from
representative duet that uh it's it it
limit cap cap the amount to $250 because
people won't pay more than
that it would it would just the
that I have a represent names a question
lottery
so the um the language that we have in
front of
us uh provides
for the
amount
that's collected from the
players uh the buyin amount collected
from the
players um that there shall be deducted
from that 35%
% 30% of that total amount uh is to be
paid to the charity
charity and the balance retained by the
game operator employer my question is
tax so the state tax is not not taken in
the same way it's taken out before okay
this division so it won't affect the
state revenue
representative
fellows so I I forgot to bring my copy
of the bill but I remember it so if we
cut back that
amount
um who Lo where where who loses or wins
in that
situation
um ideally no one loses it would be
activity if you're taking so I know this
is going to sound odd but the less the
house takes usually the more the house
sense not my question
sorry so what what we're talk so which
money so so based on the pot the Buy in
fee is a certain amount of money the Buy
in fee is a certain amount of money
which is now
split
changing so it's it's a little bit
different than before it used to be that
80% the whole pot you took 80% goes back
in prizes and 20% is split now it's sort
of the same thing except that that
that 20% is
capped and it's not expected to create a
huge loss it it's not really going to
impact it that much it will be a slight
impact but we're not expecting a big
impact from that slight
Readjustment if I could it's only in
play in very large games which of which
there are not
many I I can't think of one actually and
I'm I can't think of one where this
would apply currently so it's not a loss
it's trying to make it so that you could
have a larger game where the payout to
the players was higher or the takeout
from the house was less how we want to
look at it and I think representative
said I could probably explain it better
than I could representative said well I
I
think and your concern I share it does
not change what the the state revenue
and the most importantly the Charities
get for Revenue it doesn't change that
35% hot stop what it does is that the
the monies that are collected for that
purpose are capped at 20% as it is now
if there's a larger game or a
a uh a room wants to run a super duper
super bowl of
fker it would cap that rake that return
that revenue for the Charities at L at
$250 so it doesn't change the 35% and I
think that's where you're getting to
representative maybe I'm incorrect but
it does not change what what the uh the
revenue is for the Charities or the
state at the end of the
day let me just ask a question first
wasn't there something here where if the
number got too large it discouraged
larger players well exactly and and like
the director
said there's no history here nobody's
run a big buyin tournament like that
they do do it at some of the bigger
casinos in
Vegas Etc this was both from The
Operators and poker players that asked
for this because they saw this as you
know I'm not going to pay $500 for a
$2,500 buying if somebody chose to run
that I don't think we're going to have a
big flood of these huge tournaments it
just kind of gives them some God rails
and and it sounds like it's potentially
been an impediment we're not going to
see a huge inflow but it's it's
potentially been an impediment that gets
fellows I thought oh let's
suppose with this bill and with the way
it is now versus this bill and you had
exactly the same number of
different I'm I'm wondering if I might
what do you mean the exact same number
of players and what the director is
saying too is you you'll get a 100
players I just want to understand the
math so if you had the same number of
players with current statute versus this
one what
changes nothing unless that game
is above what what would be 1250
anything above
1250 would
if if the buying was 1250 meaning the
the Take Back The Rake was
20% 20% of 1250 is 250 yeah okay so you
would Max at a a tournament that the
buyin would be 12
$1250 250 of that so 1,000 would go to
the player pool 250 would go wouldn't
change the math at all if the buying
is500 we're talking another 20% on top
250 so basically to use that example he
just said if it was if the buying was
1500 then the um
then instead of 250 it would go to 300
and the problem as we heard in the
public session is
um you're less likely to get you know
these players are going to go other
places where the the because 20% is high
as the numbers get bigger
your Oka players are a strange
breed and will not come out for that
they just won't it it gives them this
opportunity like I
said I don't think I'm speaking wrong
when I say this doesn't change how much
money the Charities are getting this
quite frankly gives them an opportunity
to make more money because we'll have if
if there's a a premium tournament
there'll be more players that come in
benefit from that and the peripheral
play etc
etc
uh representative Le please
okay I used to be in sales part of my
career so I like to repeat what I heard
to make sure I understand it right now
we're giving up nothing and there's a
potential to make more money as a result
of this cap and I'm also hearing ought
to
pass Sly put yes representative
leapley we're not giving up nothing it's
math right like you're say saying that
if we go above this number we no longer
collect
20% it's capped at 250 so we're giving
up you know if we do run a bigger game
we're not getting 20% well tech tech
point is we're not running a bigger game
my question is why would we want to like
why do we allow gambling in the
state well technically what you said is
correct the reason we are giving
something up is because nobody is
willing to play those higher numbers
because as soon as you get into numbers
like that they'll go to Massachusetts or
somewhere else to play that so you're
I'm not sure what the advantage is to
have to run a bigger game when we're
right well you potentially so those
players may not even be coming to play
they may be going to other states so you
are potentially getting players that
wouldn't have even played so that's why
you're getting
more representative fellows yes so I
would like to say that we only raised
that cap last year and so I don't know
what the effective date is it might have
been July 1 but it you know might have
been a little bit later than that so we
don't really know if they're going to
how many people we're keeping away from
playing because we haven't even been
through a whole year yet you know I
don't know maybe they don't like to
gamble as much in the winter there sow
scares them away but we don't I hear the
I hear the sales pitch about
you know you get you're going to get
more money if if you lower essentially
it's marketing you're going to get more
money if you lower the price you're
going to get more customers if you lower
the price that may be true but it may
not be true also we really don't have
any data that proves it one way or the
1549 okay I'm going to open the work
15 providing that a two-thirds vote is
required to pass legislation imposing
taxes all right we're we're done with
that last one
uh representative PL I have difficulty
with two3 even to apply to fees and I
know some states have passed this and
representative spillsbury is not here at
the moment but he asked a question
during the public hearing would 60% be
acceptable I just want to float that out
and see if there's appetite for
two3 a question for represent restive
PL representative are are you saying you
want to change the number downward to 1
half it is 1 half now
well are you saying you want to go lower
he did not say that okay I just want to
make sure I hear it I think all he's
asking is is an appetite for something
else but um we'll decide
um yeah
representative okay represent
elme just briefly aside from the damage
that it would do to the state at some
future time uh the damage it would do to
our bond rating is
considerable when a state does not have
enough resources to um pay back for
essential kinds of services the bond
rating starts to thinking about when are
we going to
stop paying on our for our
bond Bond
payments and particularly of course when
you're putting in everything to do with
State bonds but
um the other it applies more generally
to the ability of the state to
services
representa elberger thank you Mr
chairman um when representative Osborne
was here to introduce the bill last week
one of the things he said was that we
have low taxes due to good money
management now
I would like to believe that I manage my
money well and sometimes that means
having enough money to well often it
means having having enough money to pay
my bills and just deciding that I don't
want to have as much money because
whatever reason I can't find an analogy
to
taxes if we don't have enough money to
pay our bills and we don't have enough
money to pay for likely future
bills
than not than deciding that any ways to
increase
revenues is a bad money management
practice in my mind um we are likely to
have increasing education
responsibilities from two lawsuits that
are coming up
and making sure that we can't fund them
is not good money management in my mind
uh when I asked representative Osborne
if lowering taxes or fees or not
allowing new taxes or fees requiring a
the same 2/3 majority he said no he said
in fact that maybe we would only need
onethird to pass uh lowering taxes or
fees um I find this particularly
disturbing
um the outcome will absolutely be
increasing property taxes for
our citizens for our
constituents uh and that's to me that's
about the worst way we can go about
looking at increasing taxes I want to
just mention one anecdote and this is a
totally non-representative survey uh my
husband and I really enjoy going out to
eat at diners we're big Diner people we
went to a diner in Hudson the other day
uh Suzies we love Suzies uh
and I asked the
waitress you know if this restaurant fee
restaurant tax were to be lowered how
would you feel about that she said
that's great you know I can always every
little bit helps I said if you knew that
as a result of lowering this tax your
property taxes would have to be raised
to cover the loss of revenue from
something like that how would you feel
she said I'll pay the extra 20 cents on
my restaurant bill
I think we have constituents who are
smart enough to understand
that when you Tak an action it has not
just the expected consequence but the
secondary consequence that we need to
follow what I think of is the A to B to
C rule a lot of people go from A to B
and we don't think about what happens
from B to C well B Toc is not a good
idea and I cannot in any conscience vote
to support
this okay representative
llee thank you Mr chair um along the
lines of like following logic to its
conclusion um representative Osborne
spoke on on behalf of the EFA vouchers
that passed on Thursday and that
spending is not held to a 2/3 approval
rate so we
just approved spending I think it's over
$45
million um
more not in a budget Year and that was
not held to a 2third approval rate so it
it doesn't make sense that when you're
budgeting you would hold raising money
to
this high standard and not spending
money so we can continue to increase how
much we're spending and make it harder
for us to raise funds to balance the
budget so to me this is a this is an itl
as well thank
you well the example you just gave um I
would think or not think but operates
within the current law if the current
law changed to 2/3 then that 2/3 would
have been subject to it a bill that
requires spending money if I understand
saying so if I'm this
bill it's on increasing
taxes right 2/3 is required to increase
taxes but 2/3 is not required to
increase
spending that's not addressed in the
bill you're saying so that's my concern
is that it's just as easy to spend money
which we just spent a bunch of money on
Thursday not in a like I don't know
where that money is going to come from
we did our budget last year so it seems
to me that that's introducing more
imbalance into the system to make it
harder to raise money but it's not
making it harder to spend it so we could
continue to up you know education
vouchers for example but not be able to
fund that because we can't get 2third so
it's just an analogy like what would
that look like next
time represent
umy
thank you Mr
chair having put forward a bill like
this before and heard the argument that
if you're going to um restrict raising
taxes we should restrict spending we
already restrict spending based upon the
amount of Revenue the state has because
we have a balanced budget requirement in
our
a valid argument in my opinion because
it already exists the one is directly
related to the other based upon the
amount of Revenue that comes
forward
so if we're talking about
increasing taxes on our neighbor we
should that indicates that we weren't
watching how how we were spending our
programs is a non sequitor in my
opinion thank you Mr
chair represent
elme thank you on we have a balance
balanced budget it is only balanced
until people come and put in new
spending which we did last week uh and
then sometimes in in harder times uh
when I came into the
legislature we had mostly had Republican
Governors they'd made a habit out of
spending more than we were getting in
and revenue and leaving the deficit to
the next
Governor uh that finally ended when we
got Democratic governors in and people
wouldn't be as uh interested in doing
that and I don't think at this point on
the present Governor has done that
partly because we have huge amounts of
Stir of money coming in from from the
Feds that is now
ending um
this also talks about license fees and
I'd like to take us through a little
history of that uh when I became chair
of ways and means for the first time we
had a lot of bills put in by um uh
professional
associations and
um the snowboard the
snowmobiles associations in particular
stuck with me uh uh a lot of different
associations that had a license fee
which had not been changed in 2025
years and during that time as now there
had been
inflation and they weren't getting the
services that they expected from that
license fee anymore because there wasn't
enough money in the license fee we
raised I think
253 um
fees that
year and the next year uh from people
who came before us and said we need this
done
because we want to make sure that the
the um the snowmobile paths get properly
uh dusted um leveled and uh we need this
done because we're way behind in
licensing these people um because we've
only got one person doing it because we
can't afford any more than that U
and snowmobilers stick with me because
afterwards they went to their members
and said they raised our
fees as as if it was a bad idea but they
were the ones who' asked for it on the
next term when uh the O'Brien
legislature was in place um they put in
two two people put in almost identical
bills that that uh undid everything we'd
done including cutting a couple of
things that were NE didn't need them um
and we had a six-hour he
hearing about those and we had a
six-hour hearing because uh we asked the
people who'd asked for the money to come
in and explain to us why they needed the
money and they then quietly shelved the
bills which in the Brian time was quite
something so um that's a kind of a
microcosm of what's happening when we're
we're cutting taxes that are less easily
identifiable as the service that we need
that has increased inflation has
increased cost
of and if
we
um we have been cutting quite a few
taxes in recent years on we have had
help from the federal government each
time that
disguised uh problems with
this and um we are at a juncture right
now where if we passed something like
66% of taxes being paid as property
taxes to considerably more than that and
then probably into destruction we're
already seeing destruction because there
are too
many um people who can't afford to live
away yes represent or thank you Mr chair
so I do agree with r bamy and we got to
be careful about taking any more
additional Cuts uh if I understand efas
correctly though we did not add to the
spending I thought the Money Follows the
student so if the money follow the
student the student goes to a public
charter school or a montau school or
whatever the money's just moving it's
like we're taking it here and we're
following in here so there's no increase
in the budget as far as or the spending
uh that's one point second point would
be uh yes representative Osborne did say
that uh I forget who asked the question
and uh that the the uh taking you know
reducing the taxes would only take a
third vote he was obviously being
factious uh I'd like everybody to recall
that cuz I came back and asked him I
said well you really meant or you really
would do 50% plus one and he said yes so
he wasn't he wasn't serious about that I
mean that's I thought pretty obvious so
I think we need to be careful how we do
this but you know I see the same thing
happening we we raise taxes and then we
you know red taxes and I would like to
see some stability there you know even
if it was an amendment where if we we do
something in the first year we're not
going to do it in the second year we're
going to just let it ride for a year and
then we revisit it you know when you're
when you're raising the rate and you're
lower the
rate it's hard to it's hard to get a
gauge on it uh the other thing that I
asked representative Osborne for if you
would recall is that I asked him to
provide proof of his theory of and we've
all heard it before Ronald Reagan called
the trickle down that was a term used I
think in the late 18th century also so
it wasn't new to rean but there is there
is a uh there is proof that sometimes
you reduce taxes you raise revenue and
and uh rep uh olry over here loves to
talk about the Laughing
curve
and it is a little but there's there's
that sweet spot and and when we keep
jerking things around I think we should
be letting it ride
now uh
representative PL already announced this
morning to some of you that were here
earlier that some of us already got
called out uh Yours Truly here for
voting against my bill I co-sponsored to
not reduce the tax so I'm hearing what
you're saying but I mean we got to we
need to work together and balance this
thing out but you know we're we're not
pumping the we're not pumping up
spending by supporting efas thank you
very much well I think to some of your
point there the
um evening out this thing because we do
see you know one one party gets in you
know and the other and taxes bounce
around I think the intent here by
representative Osborne was to even that
out and to smooth it out um and um you
know I'll just point out too if you look
at I don't want to diminish and I don't
the idea that there are times when you
know we have to be mindful of our income
and expenses and and getting Revenue in
however I would remind you look at a
state like California there's no limit
to how much they can keep raising taxes
and and the last thing I heard is
they're running a $ 48 billion deficit
so it's there's obviously it's a complex
interaction there's a lot of things
going on but sometimes I think you know
we we've got to be careful not to to
make it uh too simplistic representative
all you had your hand up before yeah
representative as yeah okay
representative Ames
next
thanks
there
um first uh the latest news from
California is $18 billion do instead of
48 so they're moving they're getting
better closer but $18 billion doar and
the context of New Hampshire sounds like
I don't know something that you can't
even think of I think that was
accounting trickery we talked about last
week yeah I don't know
um and then just a a comment on the EFA
discussion um I think we all know that
um many of the recipients of of uh funds
through that program um received them
for kids that have never entered into
the public schools so there's uh um it's
a new cost and um that's recognized by
the budget people I'm not saying
anything that's out of order I think
that's very clear um but I don't want to
dwell on that I think my my uh General
attitude towards this bill is that uh
for um a very very long time perhaps the
life of this this uh State as a
state uh within a federal
system um the rule has been major a
majority rule um deciding uh budgets and
other matters of importance by majority
votes and um and when it comes to to
fiscal matters we've managed to uh as a
as a a state and the community within
the state to uh find our way uh forward
and through the Maze of complicated uh
choices that have to be made just like
the household that was spoken of by
representative elberger is a complicated
choices but um we don't uh handicap one
uh approach over the other by a special
rule that would apply in this case to uh
to um new or increase taxes or license
fees um and I think we should stick with
majority rule and uh I could say a lot
of lot about how I I wish we uh uh made
different choices but I'm not going to
do that um I keep fighting for those
choices and I'm probably be uh um
discussing in a hopefully a polite way
different points of view with uh my
other colleagues in this room um but why
go to why go to this uh 2third vote
requirement um at this time we've had
had this system in place for a long time
it's honored by all the decision making
that's occurred over the years we don't
way
oh I'm sorry I I'm looking past the mic
does
no I did have my hand representative
elme I've developed a couple of things
here one uh schools have
major on fixed
costs even if you are taking people
people out of the schools the schools
usually can cut very little unless
they're starting to cut things that the
community thinks are important like arts
and stuff so um what that happens then
is that it goes on the property
tax um second California is a referendum
State and they got in serious trouble
because of that they were raising on
raising they frequently were not raising
taxes or they were stopping stopping tax
raises from going through at the same
time that they were voting for major new
benefits that cost a lot of
money and it was a crazy system I'm not
sure how it is that that they're getting
out of it uh third um the
Democrats we haven't been in that often
but when we have been in the only times
that we've raised any taxes other than
the tobacco tax that I can remember and
the tobacco tax was done uh to try to
stop young people from from
uh on smoking and it seemed to be the
only thing that anyone could prove would
stop young people from smoking um but
aside from that we did raise the fees
when people came to us and said it's
been 2025 years of
inflation on we only raised the taxes
when we got to the major
recessions and we seem to get the
recessions representative
Eary thank you Mr chair I thank uh the
representa from uh Handover
for just Lebanon close enough yeah
they're liberal up there you can't tell
one from the
other well one's to the left and one's
right let's uh let's keep our remarks
focused on the uh Hill at
hand the comments that representative
Aly
made it to my mind
bill because when we look at the
increase in the tobacco
tax the increase in the uh Trail
maintenance fee registration
p uh various other tax increases that
have passed both this committee under
both norms and and Susan's leaders
representative majors and representative
aly's
leadership had passed by a substantial
margin
18-2 20 to
nothing that's better than the 2/3
that's 100% And when they get to the
floor they passed by the 2/3 because
there was a justification for it there
was an argument presentation and due
diligence and debate that took
place
as was
outlined which is the way it should
be and as the comments were made
regarding California and a couple of
other states if you don't have those
restrictions then it becomes too
easy to wind up with massive spending
and massive
taxes
so that's something to be taken into
consideration
thank
you uh represent elberger thank you Mr
chairman may I ask representative UI a
this sure go right to it I don't have an
answer so I'm asking you um we do have a
couple of lawsuits that may require
State funding a good deal more of public
education
let's assume that that happens just for
argument
sake if we then have to fund a
significantly
larger education bill or
bills and I don't mean this kind of Bill
I mean this kind of
Bill how would you
suggest we go about doing that when my
guess is that there would not be a two
funding if a court order takes
place the bill is going to be paid one
order so there's no this and if you read
it it it has an escape clause in
those in that uh requirement the same
uh argument could be said for uh bonds
that were
due it's the same exact
argument it's required to be paid it's
going to be paid
period how we pay it that's up to
fiscal and you know we take money from
Peter to pay Paul but eventually that's
going to be
done now my other question is what what
Californian what did you have at susies
I like the Californian we can we can
take that offline given that uh we're uh
the time is getting close to 11:30 yes
representative fellow I I would just
like to um ask where is this Escape
Clause that says we would have to raise
taxes or do whatever else is needed to
pay for a court order I don't see it in
Miss
Bill if I may yes on second page the
Escape calls I think representative ol
is talking about is lines four through S
which means the treasurer is going to
take all the money that we would use for
operating in the state for paying our
services and everything it's going to
put it toward that court order which
leaves us no money to do our pay for our
citizen service
so that I think is where he came from
right well and I think I think the the
point that represent Osborne had made
was if you get to that point the
citizens are going to be very upset
there's going to be pressure on the
legislature to act uh yes represent
fellows so I what I reading that is that
has to do with Bond payments doesn't
have to do with any court order for
any anybody else anybody we haven't
heard from any new ideas thoughts
questions okay seeing none I'm going to
close the um work session on c one thing
that's a real taxing discussion thank
you for that we'll close uh the work
15 I'm going to open the work session on
HB 1116 relative to eliminating the fee
to file as a candidate for the office of
state
representative representative PL yeah
there's 400 of us this would be 800
bucks worth of lost Revenue but let's
say there's two or three candidates for
each election so that instead of 800 it
becomes 1,600 or 2400 the idea this is
small potatoes we're get paid a 100
bucks a year can we save two bucks and
the the most of that cost is eaten up by
it so your your fin I'm sorry your final
conclusion was what well that this this
is a that the money that's collected is
minimal $800 maybe up to $2,400 for the
entire State and the process of having
to collect it and keep track of it eats
up some of that oh I see okay
representative Aly thank you um we
discussed this also and on I think I
think we confirmed that the fee is paid
to the
clerk and that this is all the clerk
gets for doing all that paperwork for us
so we didn't think we ought to do
this yes repres just to add quickly to
to that statement that if we were way in
if we were Municipal and County and not
ways and means we would probably be
looking at this and saying you know
maybe we should be raising the amount
not cutting it to zero because if you
cut it to zero then this makes it an
unfunded
mandate represent
Ellery I don't know is if there's a
section in law that says that the town
clerk can't charge the $10 mandatory fee
oath because they could eliminate this
and then start charging 10 bucks each
time you you gave your oath when you uh
I I don't think so I don't think that
would
work representative Lee
please thank you Mr chair um I feel like
the the name of this is a little
misleading because it seems like it's
about
$2 um what concerns me more is if I
wanted to run for
governor uh I would have to come up with
$110,000
instead of 100 am I reading this
right so it seems like a and b are like
bill I don't think you should have to
come up with $10,000 to run for governor
so I guess that one's a bigger concern
to
me that's not in this bill I'm yeah Mr
chair so I know where she's getting it
from she's getting it it from the fiscal
note but if you look at the fiscal note
this fiscal note was was written on
October of
so I this is I don't think the fiscal
bill so are we talking about HB 116 yes
so on I'm looking on online so it
doesn't have line
numbers um but it's Roman numeral one
candidates for Governor and then you
look down to a b CDE e f all we have I
St be an attempt last session thank you
so I'm looking at oh you're looking at
the original Bill original Bill thank
you for clarifying that this whole time
I've been looking at the wrong version
thanks so as amended is what I want oh
here's
this represent
Bo my concern about taking away the $2
fee and not raising it I'm just
concerned are we going to have a flood
of candidates that just might come in
and you know want to put their name on
the ballot because it's free
let's hope so when they hear about it
they'll that's what I did it's not well
the point is when it it's the
announcement comes out if you will for a
lack of a better way of saying it oh I
can I can register for free I mean it
would seem likely that it would make
more sense to raise the fee than to
eliminate the fee can can we do
that I mean in my mind there's some cost
for the for each town to do the paper
work so um I I mean I personally can go
either way on this but I'm I'm more
inclined to just leave this the way it
is leave the $2
because if the $2 is a barrier to entry
for you to apply for state
representative then you have bigger
problems because because you're only
going to get $100 a year uh to do the
job representative
Ames my only comment on that is didto I
oh
uh represent ery could we modify it to
require a $2 bill be
used we could but that might not be a
good
comments
okay thank you and we will close the
hp16
I'm not going to open the uh public
hearing on HB
1054 relative to the northern border
Alliance program
fund representative plet we heard
testimony about how few
people were uh coming across that narrow
stretch of northern border and my
reaction was that's because we have this
northern border Alliance program in
place it it it's so small um now I did
raise questions whether it needed as
much money as it got uh after after
hearing that but I I'm not in favor at
all of uh eliminating the northern
border Reliance program keep it in place
secure yeses has nothing to do with
eliminating the northern border Alliance
program it has to do with removing
every two
years the excess that has not been
spent because it was not
needed
fund which which then means that it has
to be uh
reallocated uh every two years well I
take it yes it it has to be the way it's
written as I understand it it does uh
have to be reallocated every two years
to continue
anyway but if they
spend ,000 of it and don't spend the
rest uh in the two years when
everybody's worried about immigration
from Canada uh okay then
um I think Canada is also so worried
way well I I think one one of the things
that
um they they were saying was the um
what's that the whole broad area there
um not tri-state area SW Swan thank you
um that there has been an increase in
that area and they were claiming not
much of an increase in our area but if
we I think the concern was that if we
get rid of our um if we don't refund
ours to the correct level wouldn't it be
human nature that people would then
start funneling across the Northern New
Hampshire border representative fellows
um yes so this bill does only one thing
right now that's a non-aps fund so the
money goes in and at the end of the year
it if there's any
leftover it's not um
sent to it's not sent to doesn't become
Surplus and they would need an
appropriation every year anyway there's
no really no reason why this can't be
treated like a regular budget item and
Appropriations made for it every two
years I looked up what this money can be
spent for it can be spent on
overtime um for officers which can be
State Police or it can be local local
police or Homeland Security or even
fishing game it can be used for training
of of those uh participating officers
including the overtime that they might
uh need when they're uh participating in
the training they can use it for
equipment but but the area they're
covering is restricted to within 25
miles of the border
so and it's wooded that's one of the
issues about people come could come
through there um so what would they need
for equipment maybe they need some ATVs
I don't I don't think may people would
try to come over in the winter but maybe
some snowmobiles not any huge piece
expensive piece of
equipment and the other um restriction
is that well they can't use it to for
confidential informants and they can't
use it to supplant any um local budgets
so it's primarily based on expenditures
for for overtime and for just regular um
hourly rate I looked at the budget at
the expenditure so far this year what
they had um not the budget the
expenditure report and they hadn't
really spent very much I can't remember
how much but it wasn't very much and it
was primarily for the salaries so I
don't think that they're going to
there's any loss to the program for
having it at having the amount of money
laps at the end of the year and treating
fund I would just ask the question
rather than making a statement the
question in my mind would be at a time
is this the right time to do something
like this when we know that we have a
huge concern at the Southern border and
we have seen numbers increasing
dramatically on the Northern side I
would just ask why why now um it might
be something to let's just see how
things go for a while before making a
drastic uh change yes representative
leap Lee thank you um I think it's
precisely for the reason you say right
because across our budget our needs
change every single year and if we have
if our budget is locked into these
savings accounts for different uses then
we can't be responsive so I think we do
it for exactly the reason you're saying
like this year maybe they're going to
spend their entire um allotment which is
great that's what the money's there for
but it doesn't mean that if they're not
spending it this year that they're
definitely going to need twice as much
the next year right so I think exactly
to your point if we want to be
responsive we shouldn't just let money
like build up in these little pockets we
should let it be
accessible cuz yes this year maybe they
do need it all representative
Aly yes we did get uh verified by the
um
attorney um see what what do they call
them the the district attorney for New
Hampshire on who is part of the state
Depart of the um AG's office in DC on
the data that showed that New Hampshire
had something what was it
um encounters and um and apprehensions
both encounters and in
apprehensions whereas the rest of the
sector had a great deal more and the
reason that that seems to be true is
that the northern our nor part of the
northern border is is not just forested
it's also filled with with
brush and it's
pretty I went and and straddled with my
sister a number of years ago the the um
top the beginning of the top Lake in in
New Hampshire which is very close to the
border and we
bushwacked and it was really difficult
go
and on
Maine when I was younger there was a
road that went straight through the
middle of the Northern woods of Maine
and across the border into Canada and
everybody used it and there was no no
border patrol at
all um and they said these are the
people that are going going up with drug
F that use that um they um they manage
their forests rather different way than
we do so okay um yes representative
roachford again I'm gonna probably get
off topic here but just want to provide
some perspective of what the Border
looks like up there I'm from from the
area um my neighbor is a border patrol
agent uh you know regardless of what we
heard in testimony there are have been
significant increases in apprehensions
up there um you know his his his again
um
anecdotal testimony to me is it's people
that largely are living in Montreal the
families have been there for a long time
and they're looking at what's going on
with our border and they're saying hey
maybe now's the time to go and they go
um they're not bushwacking primarily
what we're seeing there Hall stream and
Pittsburgh is a crossing point it's you
you can you can cross there and get your
ankles wet and that's that's where it is
but you know one of the things that we
we have to take into account is the size
of our border you know it's a very small
border it's 52 miles 58 miles but to put
that into perspective 58 miles if you
were standing down at the hookit Welcome
Center 58 miles would get you to
Plymouth that's a huge amount of
territory I mean we we say it's a small
amount of ter territory but it's but
it's uh but it really is quite large so
it wouldn't take much I think anyone
could probably slip through that here
around this table Yeah I voted against
this when it came to on the house floor
a year ago because quite frankly I don't
think it's the state's responsibility to
be enforcing our national borders but
the reality is again from up there uh
hearing the people up there the concerns
of the people that I live with and grew
up with it is a concern uh of of of
what's happening and it isn't you know
the picture that we're getting down here
is different than what's actually
happening up there
um I get it this is all about a lapsing
fund versus a non-aps fund uh I would be
a I I think that that you know it's
taken me a year to get to this place but
I think the fund is worthwhile I think
the the program is
worthwhile um and you know for the at
the end of the day it may or may not
make a difference whether it lapses or
not I don't know but if it means uh
showing support for the program um again
I've come 180 degrees on this and after
listening to my my neighbors um you know
I I think that I I I would vote against
this 1054 U I think it has Merit and you
know I want to signal that it does have
Merit to the people that that I live
with um up North so that's just my
thoughts on it thank you representa
elberger thank you Mr chairman one of
the pieces of information that I found
particularly important was that uh we
already get Federal money and we haven't
used all of it uh and we're not looking
at getting rid of the program we are
simply saying let's lapse the fund and
reappropriate as we need it so if the
fund is entirely used as representative
leapley said entirely used within the
bium
we we're happy it's being used for its
stated purpose and if we need as much
again fine if we don't need as much we
can consider it but we should be looking
at the fact that we're not using the
funding that we already have for that
you
okay thank you I'll close the um work
session on HB
now open the work session on HB 1193
relative to the establishment of a child
program so I if I will can Mr chairman
this was a bill that I actually worked
on quite a bit over the summer and um I
think representative Sweeney
uh told the committee that he had a
similar bill that got in uh a day before
mine did so um he he I I was not allowed
to put my bill in so we combined the two
characteristics of the bill and what we
got was um not what either one of us had
intended and then there was some
questions at OS of you know who you know
did we miss a cut we missed a cutof date
for for um for uh revision I've got some
amendments that are not quite done yet
um that I think would clarify some of
the questions that were brought up in
the committee uh in speaking with uh
some some folks on the other side of the
aisle on this and and in the other
chamber uh I had some good
recommendations on the fact that and and
this was a confusion point when at
testimony is we have a scholarship
program now in the state for lower
income folks and the design of this was
actually to continue to use the
scholarship program for those folks but
it's just that next step up that needs
help I mean it's that
you know when you make a dollar or two
more than the cut off line and you miss
out you're you're you actually take a
step back rather than a step forward and
that's what this was designed to do is
to catch that middle point and then you
know the means testing was also to the
point where if you made above a certain
point you wouldn't qualify so it was
initially really designed to hit a
certain segment of people uh that wasn't
it wasn't captured in the version that
we got um if if the if we could I I
would like a little more time on this to
work on this um you know and and come up
with a better Amendment if not I
understand and um would would you know
be representative
Ames I think that is what we need we
need a little more time um if we can
have it uh to um get that information
that you've developed get
the new draft Amendment and um
understand it and act on it uh but uh we
need a little time to do that I think
we've got the time I hope we
do okay um yes represent PL
representative Rochford might have
answered my question I don't know but on
line
11 it reads uh employee must earn
between 103 and 50% of the federal
poverty guidelines and I I Circle 100%
why couldn't they make lower than that
is that's because is a separate section
well that that as as it was my
understanding working with another you
know official here um those folks
earning less actually do qualify for a
scholarship program already in the state
of New Hampshire which um so so we
didn't want
to we wanted to ensure it was the people
at most vulnerable and most risk uh that
you know the lower income earners but
we're still earning we're still working
and uh the Working Poor if you will um
um and and maybe even one step a little
bit above that who are doing well
they're they're making progress in life
they're they're they're they're they're
they're seeing
successes and that's the worst thing we
want to see is when you're seeing
successes in life you take a program
that they've you know that has helped
that and then all of a sudden knock them
down you know far back so it it was more
of a gradual implementation over this
and that's where and that's the area
that's one of the areas that really does
need some work that I have I think a Sol
solution
for how much time do you think you need
for a
solution I I think I could have
something next week and or or I mean if
we wanted to collaborate with other
folks on this do a subcommittee like we
were talking about I think that you know
we could do that too I think we have
until March on this um to get it out of
this committee but I do have a lot of
work put aside um that I've done on this
so I think I could probably move this
along pretty quickly okay represent elmy
yeah I want to emphasize that tax
credits are a draw on our revenues which
is unpredictable unless you can do
enough research to figure out okay how
how much is this likely to cost if we
expand it to 300% or whatever of of uh
poverty there's a limit on this 10
million so if there is a limit on it of
10 million that may very well
be
uh less than they get in
applications and you need to try to do
all of the work to figure out
um what are you going to do is it going
to be prated like like the research and
development tax credit uh what would the
timing be in terms of people finding out
whether they were going to get enough so
that they could afford to pay for the
child
care sure so thank you yes and it was
based on the the research tax credit and
that's where we kind of took the um the
the bulk of the the the the uh structure
of this and at the end of the day the
the the people are going to the the the
people the residents are going to
benefit IM immediately because their
employer is going to pay to going to pay
for their health their child care um it
would be the employer that's taking that
risk and it would be delayed a year and
they would know you know it may not be
100% it may be you know depending on how
the popularity of the the program is we
set the or I set the the uh you know and
again I I'm speaking for another
representative here but we when when I
did the research over the summer I put
the number at 10 million because I
wanted to go guard rail on it I didn't
want it to be a runaway program I didn't
want it to be aund million program but I
wanted it to be something where somebody
if if employers were were taking part in
it there would be enough in there for
you if you set it at
$500,000 and that that's going to chew
that up if you've got a 100 employees
employers taken care of so so that was
the the thought process but yes there
was a there's a stop on it and there was
stop was intentional because we don't
want to we don't want this to be a
runaway program
as the research and development tax
credit became and that's we said we
started it at 1 million I think and uh
not one million but we started it at a
one and uh a few years later pressure
from the B Bia had gotten it up to 10
and at that point people said hey wait a
minute and and stopped the growth of it
but but anytime they could come in and
say we need
15 because they are having to prate it
yeah and I think that's we have an
opportunity as a you know to we we can
talk about what's the right number I
mean we you I I took ADV I I'm one that
has taken advantage of the research tax
credit I mean it's it's phenomenal it's
funded you know equipment Investments
it's it's funded a lot of things so so
you know having used some of these
things to grow a business stabilize a
business uh having been affected having
not been able to grow a business because
I don't have child care or my my
employees don't have child care I can
you know I'm not a I was not a small
business person but uh these are the
kinds of things I think we can help in
but you know we are the experts on tax
credits you know whether we like it or
not right under this uh under under the
gold Dome so um that's why I'd like some
more time to really work and chew this
up and if it doesn't have legs it
doesn't have legs but I think that I
think that you know knowing the top
topic of child care I mean I think we
owe it to the people in New Hampshire to
to put a little time into it and at
least see if this is the right Avenue or
the right direction to do this yeah the
topic is really important the problem is
that the cost is incredibly
huge representative fellows thank you um
I I like the idea of people getting more
child care Heth
um I it when I look at this to try to
put it together seems to me to be really
complicated because one of the things
representative Barry told us is that
um the people who qualify for the
existing program which are like the
vouchers that they get different amounts
of money depending on what their income
is and in the fiscal note it tells us
that they call that the child uh care
scholarship program and that people in
that program can have an income up to
250% of the poverty limit so there are
people already in that program that are
kind of like um aging out of it that
they're they're they're um voucher I'll
call it a voucher it's
shrinks so to try to put two different
sources feeding help for child care I
think that they're not going to be in
sync because the business is going to
help with their people some of which
maybe are already there may be somebody
in in the existing program that's
getting close to that to say they're at
200% of property so they're getting some
money and then they're going to fill in
different amounts for different
employees depending if they don't get
any now and I think the whole thing to
try to meld the two together seems
really
complicated yeah and I agree with you
100% And and that was one of the areas
where when we put the two bills together
uh represent Swede and I were like we
got to fix this because this isn't what
we intended and this is this is going to
get real confusing and it did get
confusing um I think I have something
that will cut that confusion U because
when we were again and we were you know
blame it on my rookie status you know I
wasn't clear on um some of the dates and
cut off lines and whatnot um but these
were all he he and I were communicating
and lo and behold the date the P the the
the time passes and we you know we
missed it but you're absolutely right
100% when we heard the testimony when
you start mixing all these programs
together it was this is far more
confusing than I had ever intended and
it's definit and it's more confusing
than he ever intended and we recognize
that uh that's why I think we can get
something that would at least if we can
cut back some of the static if you will
and focus on on on what we're trying to
do here I think it will make more sense
and a little more time I think would
would help with
that represent Aly yeah there's another
problem here which is that page two is a
totally different program and expense
note the child care tax credit uh for
expenditures for maternity or paternity
leave greater than 12 weeks which is
another thing that the Democrats would
like to have but um it's kind of does
this stay in there because it's
not the fiscal the school note didn't
seem to notice
it yeah that's that's a good question
that was not part of the work that I had
initially brought forward as part of
Representative Sweeny which again when
we're talking about it maternity and
paternity leave as a as a small employer
you know I can speak for a small
employer that's something that you'd
love to be able to to to provide and and
and give but there's generally not a lot
left in the pot to to do that so we felt
that incentivizing this at the end of
the day this this bill just incentivizes
employers to to do certain things and um
and and hopefully there's some help to
do it um that's a good question that was
you know we can okay we can chew that up
I like the I when when he mentioned that
to me I like the idea again I think in
my business we've had six kids um you
know over the course of 15 years so not
my kids but uh employees kids but um you
know so I I can relate to that I
understand that and I understand what
folks go through so um but you're right
that wasn't part of the fiscal note I
don't know why that was missed but uh
but I think you know we can you know
that may or may not stay we can talk
about that and another thing which may
be or may not be complicating is that
the
um
on Community Development Loan Fund I
think it's called I can't remember now
um
they
on this has been going for a very long
time and one of the things that it does
is to uh provide money to employers to
build child care
centers that could have people from
outside of the business but that are
basically for the business um that get
tax credits that they then have to go
sell to people people in order to do it
I don't think it's done a lot of child
care though yeah I
um if I may I we I looked at that we I
so there I think there was about 17
states around the country that do
something for child care and of course
we don't even income tax for for
individuals so a lot of those programs
were based on individual income tax some
of them were based on exactly what you
were talking about large employers
building things and I think you're right
you can buy tax credits for that but you
know aside from a few larger employers
it's mostly small employers you know
that are paying business profit tax or
business Enterprise taxes um so you know
being creative on how to how to how to
work around that is where we you we
targeted that but it's not a new idea
it's not a New Concept there's many
states and I don't think any state is
exactly the same everyone's doing it uh
differently and U you know so I think we
okay seeing no more hands we'll close
1193 next up hb1 1470 establishing a
study committee on the feasibility and
impact of lowincome housing tax
credit representative PL I just have
questions what possible tax credit could
there be that applies to low income
that's a state tax uh swept they're
they're not paying that directly anyway
if they're low income more likely
renting so I'm not sure what the study
committee would come up with anything
but I'm not opposed to a study committee
representative
Aly yes um I'm not sure where I stand on
this now because I really don't like tax
credits but uh
the the what they mean by a lowincome
housing tax credit is a tax credit for a
one or more on groups that are together
building a
lowincome
development not directly to lowincome
people but of course don't need a tax
credit and the tax credit is applied to
what the BPT yeah it is something that
is done in most places in the country
the ones with income taxes or big sales
taxes
um
and but I personally don't understand
what three people meeting together after
they've been appointed by the speaker
and the the president of the Senate are
with in a few
months represent of Fells so I I have
you know um when the sponsor was here he
gave us a piece of paper with something
written in to be an amendment but we
don't have a official Amendment do we no
but the only thing that he did was he he
said that they could also study other
tax incentives to increase the
production and affordability of housing
legislation which it could do anyway but
November yes so so I I
would support
this if we could get the amendment
except that I where where it says um the
the addition and other tax incentives I
would just like to cross out the tax so
it could be they can study lowincome
housing tax credits
and other incentives to you know look at
the possibly helping the situation just
not to be so restrictive that it's even
just tax incentives and I'm my
expectation would be that um whoever's
on the committee would be spending
pretty much all of their time with New
Hampshire Housing Authority and to
better understand what's already in
place and seeing if they new the Housing
Authority has any recommendations on
useful um the Housing Authority is
comment thank thank you for your
Indulgence Indulgence Mr chair Ben Frost
deputy director Chief legal officer at
New Hampshire housing we would but we
are the state's um administrator and
allocator of the federal low-income
housing tax credit which as
representative Aly described is is an
incentive for private Market developers
to do this sort of stuff um and it works
really well of the mic please and many
sorry many and many states do have a
state uh low-income housing tax ta
credit uh we stand ready to uh help a
study committee uh even if it is just
three people uh to uh provide as much
information as we possibly can on what
other states are doing and what might be
Hampshire representative
Ames yeah um I sort of asked this
question last time
um but I I don't think it was answered
um and I did some exploring subsequently
my question relates to for States as
opposed to the federal level um what
exactly are the taxes against which the
credit is taken and um in New Hampshire
as we all know there's no income tax or
nor a general sales tax um but but I did
find out that in some other states
um uh the credit is taken against well
in one case the insurance an insurance
tax another case a
business tax would' be some parallel to
our own business profits tax um and um I
don't know whether you've got more
information on the because that's that's
something that stuck out of me we're
talking about tax credit tax credit
against what we're
where's the money coming from or coming
out of what pot uh we really need to
know that and so if you've got any
insights on that I'd appreciate it well
just off the cuff representative Ames I
I think the uh most likely uh taxes to
take a credit against would be the
business profits tax and the business
Enterprise tax also the insurance
premiums tax uh th those are uh subject
to other tax credits uh already uh in
existence in New Hampshire
um we we would all obviously look at
others but you know those are the the
big drivers and those are those are the
ones where the uh businesses that might
be
investors uh uh in this sort of um
interest commenting on this um
that uh
this is uh the kind of matter that I
think we should seriously look at and
explore um I'm not sure we can afford
going very deep with such a tax credit
this kind of tax credit but let's look
at it and figure that out uh housing
lowincome housing is uh we don't have
enough of it I mean that's all I can say
on that score by a long shot and uh so
why not let's explore it I would like to
see an amendment that added to the
members of the commit membership of the
committee I think three is I'm not sure
I've seen a a committee like this set up
with just three people or maybe it's
maybe it is a practice I don't know but
uh but it's it it gets to be very
difficult to organize meetings and uh
you know to have the
work uh force in the committee uh
sufficient to get the job done and to
have a range of points of view too and
we definitely want to be sure that you
know the range of viewpoints on this
kind of issue in the legislature is
represented on the committee it's hard
to do that with three
leapley thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question um it so what I hear
you saying is that other states have
incentives in place is that correct that
is correct okay um it seems to me like
what I hear people addressing is whether
they think a tax credit is a good idea
or not I don't think that's the question
I think the question is precisely
um to explore this right like that's
what a study committee does and I what I
hear from business owners for example
I'm thinking like you know Main Street
Manchester you look and you're like are
there apartments above every single one
of these businesses and as it turns out
there aren't and why not because it's
super expensive right so are there ways
that we can can support people who would
want to
invest in our main streets and you know
put in the sprinkler system or you know
could they do this floor and then that
floor it seems like basically what we're
saying is do we want to help solve this
problem do we want to sit around a table
and talk about you know what are other
states doing what are other incentives
Beyond tax incentives
and um I think it's true that people's
really small um having attended the the
uh big study on uh worldwide taxation I
found it really helpful to invite
experts in and here I feel like that's
how we we grow and learn what's out
there as possible and maybe even
innovate as a state because I think we
are very Innovative and I think that
would it creates a space where we can
think about this very very important
issue so I'm in favor of this thanks
thank
you representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman Mr Frost
are you aware of um programs through the
federal GSA the general Services
Administration and Department of
Transportation where they are looking to
uh basically offload some of their
buildings that they're not using anymore
and I see that you are are there any
unused Federal buildings in the state
that
some work could be applied
to thank you for that question and and I
acknowledge that GSA does have a process
for Surplus um know Surplus Federal
property uh I I've not looked into this
closely uh I I know that
well I hesitate to bring it up but the
McIntyre building in Portsmouth um is
one such building uh that you know was
Federal property and and the city's
trying to figure out what to do with it
uh but I'm sure there are others as well
uh with regard to State Surplus property
yes uh there in fact there is a very um
uh effective process
for state agencies to declare uh
property that they control as Surplus to
the needs of the state and that goes to
other agencies first to see if they have
the need for the property and can
transfer it from one agency to another
and then if if that is not the case then
um then it gets put through a process
where it's offered and depending upon
how the property was acquired by the
state than it is offered to the
municipality in which it is situated and
or New Hampshire housing uh and in some
circumstances we have a preemptive right
to acquire uh those properties if we
want to we have a great working
relationship with the Department of
Transportation and we're in negotiations
right now on several Parcels of property
um I I was on a couple of Zoom calls
with the GSA and the Federal Department
of Transportation at the end of last
year they are happy
to not give but help to give at
incredibly low
rates um including wonderful financing
systems as bonds ra as as loans rather
than as bonds
um and I would hope that we are looking
at Federal
properties if there are any in the state
I don't know enough about Federal
properties in the state with your
prompting I I suspect we will be please
do and and uh I have they would they
would not do any recordings but I took
you uh representative
Rochford yes thank you Mr chairman just
I just got to I'm just looking back at
the bill here it's pretty open-ended I
mean there's not really a lot of the
objectives are not defined per se other
than it's to study a feasibility of
low-income tax credit you may have said
this before is there some type of
Federal grant program behind this or is
this strictly what we can do as a state
representative great question and I
think the answer is uh remains to be
seen I'm sorry that this yeah I know
that's part I get it every day
um I think I can do that without
unplugging it
um so in in other states uh there are uh
state tax credits that work in alignment
with the federal low-income housing tax
credit and it's possible for New
Hampshire to design something like that
to leverage uh the federal programs uh
also uh it it's possible to come up with
something that is is flexible and can do
that leveraging Federal resources or
that also works independently of federal
resources in cases where the the federal
programs don't work that well okay thank
you can I add I like my colleague here I
I would support this um you know this is
a need you know especially in
my my part of the world uh housing is a
huge issue and and and I look at it you
know we've got business that can't grow
because they can't hire people and they
can't hire people because they have no
place to put them um and we've got
buildings on lanc on Main Street in
Lancaster that have Apartments the only
way to get them is the companies to buy
the buildings so uh to put these in
there the only thing that I would
actually perhaps put together as an
amendment is to change the spectrum of
the study is to look at uh lowincome and
Workforce housing uh because it's not
just low-income housing that we're
needing up north it's Workforce housing
it's people that you know have a skill
have a trade U but even with that they
can't they can't find a place to live
and I personally as you couldn't tell I
like tax credits I've used them um you
know I think that they can be managed uh
but again this is an opportunity to to
study it I mean it's not we're not it's
not costing us anything to take a look
at and at the end of the day we may find
out that it's not works but I think uh I
could get behind this with a couple of
tweaks
okay any yes
representative I would just like to know
is someone from this committee going to
stop by and see
the sponsor about making an amendment
I'm happy to is that all right with you
Mr chairman well the spon yeah the
sponsor doesn't have to make the
Amendments well I understand that I just
and follow up on
this instead of two members of the House
what would this committee think of a
higher number like
you said
Le
all right so this would be one bill that
we will so most likely not EXA tomorrow
because uh it sounds like some
additional information is needed yes so
I would like to suggest um four house
members in specify that two are
Democrats and two are
[Music]
Republicans just I'm thinking that
Republicans are really good at focusing
on on tax credits and I think the
Democrats may have some other
perspectives you know I don't want to
get you know end up with only looking at
tax credits cuz I think that there are
other opportunities
too okay represent Aly yes um
I thank you I set up 12 years ago now a
committee to try to do something about
the massive condominium problems and um
the Senate took their second member off
it and nobody added an extra House
quorum well there'll be one
Senator yeah yeah
sure you mean three house members and
one Senator that's what we
had
four house one Senator that's five yeah
that's
fine okay so it sounds like a couple
members are going to work uh together to
come up with a possible Amendment on
this um yeah and I just wanted to add
something there a lot I'm not I don't
think it's terribly been terribly
effective but a lot of work has been put
into Workforce housing
already um that the
lowincome has
had the the governor put a 100 million
into it this last
term um and was forced by the executive
Council to add a little bit of lowincome
housing in it uh I'm not sure how that's
working
but but but
uh I don't know if it expanded into to
low
income lowi income is a very different
kind of animal
than than
Workforce in my opinion at least uh but
it does include the workforce part that
most people don't think of as Workforce
which is all of the supporting
characters that keep keep a business
working your cleaners
and maybe the
secretaries if there are any left did
you have a response to that or U not
that you have to have one I was just I I
I would note that uh Workforce housing
has a
specific uh and precise definition under
New Hampshire law and that is found in
RSA
674 59 I believe um and it is housing
rental housing that is Affordable to a
family of three that makes uh up to um
60% of the area median
income uh and that's at a 30% cost
burden that's paying no more than 30% of
their income or a um home for purchase
that is Affordable at 100% of the median
income uh area median income for a
family of four so that it's very clear
what constitutes Workforce housing
low-income
housing um it depends on which
definition you're looking at and there
are multiple
definitions generally speaking it's on
the rental side it is close to the
definition of Workforce housing um so I
think I think there would be no harm in
adding Workforce housing they in they
are often times roughly equivalent
Workforce and low-income housing where
they differ is on the purchase side
because we don't typically talk about
low income and purchase housing together
okay um representative elberger had her
hand thank you Mr chairman just pointing
out that in
Nashua where we have just as many other
communities a significant homeless
population many of them are working two
jobs a couple I spoke with each of them
was working two jobs and still could not
afford a place to rent so I would
support the notion of adding Workforce
housing into this represent all me
follow by fellows I'm not sure whether
we Sorry whether we'd need to Define
Workforce again within this bill if we
include Workforce because the governor's
program was definitely not focused on
is there a definition of Workforce
housing in the rsas or
no yes that is
okay you could also on other levels of
income you could make reference
to RSA
204c colon 57 I believe believe uh which
is a subdivision in the um New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority statute that
deals with the affordable housing fund
and so there are different levels of
income that are very specific similar to
uh the way Workforce housing is
defined represent fellows so that last
one you mentioned is that for buying a
house or is can is that for apartments
that's either
either well I think that's why we need
the study
committee you give us that reference the
second reference is RSA 204 hyphen C
674 colon
59 that's work Force
search Okay anything
else seeing none close the work session
on hb1
1470 we have one
um it's 12:30 but maybe we can uh finish
this up
um unless anyone's opposed to trying to
finish that up before lunch no I'm
seeing none okay I'm going to open the
work session on
HB
1613 establishing a trust fund for money
from Soil and Water environmental
contamination Court settlements
representative uh plat I often lead off
and maybe I shouldn't because I'm
getting but to me this is a no-brainer
the pass because it's money that's
coming for uh for
violations of by for Soil and Water
environmental contamination yet it's
going into the general fund we should
put it in a trust fund for that purpose
and it's got it says if it's not after
used by after two years it could be
moved uh and I think that's a good
idea representative
Aly thank you um we discuss this a lot
in caucus and there are a number of of
problems with it that representative
moose is already working on and we'd
really like to give him the
time on to absorb all of of for instance
um the the example he was using of
contamination uh I forget what substance
it was but it was uh outlawed in the 70s
and it was uh
was contaminating on land and they
they've cleaned up the land but in the
process it went down into the waters we
don't know if there's any way to clean
up that
substance in the water in the water is
very a very difficult thing and so the
the money would just sit there for two
years and then get put in these other
and two years doesn't seem like quite
enough to figure out how we're going to
handle this either uh so
um
he's and it's obvious that it would only
be for smaller level contaminations
because when it's past they're going to
put it all in one one new
section um so there could be quite a lot
of these little things things for a
while hanging around for two years
before they go off into one of the two
two
funds and that isn't what they really
meant to be
doing so he's he's work he'd already
realized some of this and he's working
on it and um we're
communicating we'd like
uh to be able to to put it off for a
later
time
okay
repres
question see an amendment come back in
here yeah put it into a committee study
or something sub committee something
yeah he has a partial Amendment now but
it was just his first draft that we all
got well are you looking for a work
study on once his Amendment comes back
oh wait I meant I meant work session but
mean okay anything else on this
one okay seeing none I'm going to close
the work session on 163 hb1
1613 um before we go I just want to
let's just recap on the ones that need
more time um obviously the one we just
discussed
1613 um sounds 1193 the child care tax
program um because this whole list is is
the list for tomorrow to be potentially
exec along with 1254 which I see we have
an amendment before
us
um what other was there anything else
uh representative du said spring an
amendment on 1525 but we should have
that for
tomorrow um representative PL you're
going to have an amendment for
1203 J for four puted in for me okay so
you just have to make sure that we have
that for tomorrow
yes
um so other than other than that it
looks like um there's only two that were
holding off right now is that true 1193
and 1613 or feel like there was one
missing yeah 12 that's representative PL
is bringing
1470 oh right for uh right so 1470
that
1389 that's the lottery one that
it to put back 35% no no no no no I
think that was the anonymous yeah that
we we found that had some
errors in it 1389 to me is an itl for
the moment the the the notes I have is
that we're either going to go itl or is
on that um so I think we can do that
tomorrow
just the one with the putting the 35% is
1203 I'd to just mention that the
amendment that I passed out um I the
first time read the two parts of it
together and they don't make sense
together uh there was one word uh that I
need to change on line 20 which is not
the 800 uh 184 days of the uh meals and
rooms tax requirement uh microphone
please oh sorry
on I we need to change just one thing uh
online 20 chain um the amendment 124
1254 yeah that we didn't discuss what
does that have to change to uh to 30
because it's 30 above so 184 changes to
30 yeah okay it would be much different
limit can you make sure that we have
that first than the rooms and meals
tax which by the way is 184 days okay so
you can get that can you I didn't I
didn't catch that so line so the
amendment that we have for 1254 line
20 it says 184 days that's going to
change to 30 and and I'll go get that as
soon as we've had our other
meeting do we have two
amendments I just have one it's uh
1254 the amendment uh Amendment uh
where's line
20 here's mine only goes to 11 you got
the short hand version you got the
original one I put one on your in your
place it's Aly Buco it's a joint
Amendment
okay all right I think um so so really
it's the last three that we will not
take up tomorrow
1470 and
1613 the rest of them we will take up
tomorrow plus 12:54 and representative
Al is going to get a um an update to
line 20 all right I don't have anything
else um let me just look at the
schedule for next week so we'll all um
we'll see you uh tomorrow at 10 o'clock
for the exec session and then next the
um actually the following week Happ
what's that it's going to be it's not
Monday's a holiday so we are not meeting
Monday uh we will meet Tuesday I haven't
put that together yet as to what that
might be a combination of public
hearings I think there's there's either
three or four new bills that we have in
um uh I I don't know I just I looked
before we started there was 18 bills in
our committee we had I'm not sure it was
28 or 29 a few days ago so we
dispatched I believe 11 of them so that
I think there's four new ones so so um
between So the plan is to meet Tuesday
and Wednesday next week I don't can't
tell you exactly what that'll be yet it
probably be a combination of work
session public hearing and U possibly
EXA just one day um I don't know yet
because it kind of depends what happens
so what's
that
I've been kind of sticking with 10 I
mean I but you know that's subject to
change until this goes in tomorrow but
it wouldn't be any earlier than 9:30 do
right
oh
um okay so you'd rather start at 10: on
Tuesday for that reason okay yeah I knew
there was something okay so it's
Wednesday that potentially could start
at 9:30 if we have U if we have a need
for that all right that's all I have any
there's no questions then we will see
you
tomorrow